>> GREG: WELCOME BACK.
SO, THIS IS THE PART OF THE SHOW
WHERE WE HAD STANDUP COMEDY ALL
WEEK BUT WE RAN OUT OF COMICS.
WHY NOT READ FROM STEVE DOOCY'S
BOOK OF RECIPES.
WHO DOESN'T LOVE A GOOD RECIPE.
>> I CAN DO IT.
>> GREG: WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
WHOLE SEGMENT TO STEVE DOOCY'S
NEW BOOK.
>> I CAN DO IT.
I BROUGHT MY MICROPHONE ALREADY
>> GREG: I PROMISED STEVE DOOCY.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO LISTEN
ABOUT GRUTEN FREE SPA GET TY OR
LISTEN TO THE ONE AND ONLY CAT?
>> I'VE BEEN CARRYING THIS
MICROPHONE ALL WEEK WAITING FOR
MY SHOT.
SEE HOW IT GOES.
NO MATTER HOW BAD YOUR LIFE IS
GOING, THERE'S SOMEBODY ON THE
INTERNET WHO HAS IT WORSE AND IS
BEING VERY OPEN ABOUT THAT.
I HAVE A FEW FRIENDS ON FACE
BOOM THAT ARE BLOWING UP MY FEED
WITH THE MOST DEPRESSING STUFF
IN THE WORLD.
LIKE -- GUESS IT'S ANOTHER NIGHT
AT HOME WATCHING TV BY MYSELF
UNLESS SOMEONE WANTS TO CALL ME
BUT THEY WON'T BECAUSE NO ONE
EVER DOES.
YO, THAT'S BECAUSE YOU MADE IT
CLEAR THAT YOU SUCK.
NO ONE IS GOING TO INVITE YOU TO
THE PARTY IF THEY'RE WORRIED
YOU'RE GOING TO SOB VIOLENTLY AT
IT.
MAKE EVERYBODY THINK THINGS ARE
GOING BETTER THAN THEY ARE.
IT'S LIKE A PADDED BRA FOR YOUR
LIFE. THE INTERNET CAN MAKE YOU
SAD SOMETIMES TOO, THOUGH,
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF VERY
HOT PEOPLE ON THERE.
OKAY?
I CLIP FAKE HAIR INTO MY ACTUAL
HAIR EVERY DAY BECAUSE I FEEL
LIKE I HAVE TO KEEP ONE THE
KARDASHIAN, RIGHT?
BUT I'M NOT SURE HOW MUCH IT
REALLY MATTERS.
BECAUSE IN ALL OF MY EXPERIENCES
WITH MEN, I KNOW MEN CANNOT TELL
IF A WOMAN HAS GOOD HAIR.
THEY DON'T KNOW.
I'VE NEVER SEEN GUYS AT A BAR
POINTING AT A GIRL AND GO, OH,
DID YOU SEE THAT GIRL BROOINL'S
-- BRIAN'S TALKING TO?
HER HAIR HAS LIKE NO VOL YUM --
VOLUME.
SHOULD HAVE SEEN THE HAIR ON THE
GIRL I WAS WITH LAST NIGHT.
THE SHEEN, BRO, THE SHEEN.
WOMEN, WE ARE WAY TOO INSECURE
FOR NO REASON. I DO NOT MEAN
THAT IN THE BODY POSITIVITY WAY.
BECAUSE, THE BODY POSITIVITY.
THEY MAKE -- THOSE PEOPLE,
EVERYTHING WORSE, RIGHT?
DO YOU REMEMBER THE DOVE SOAP
NORMAL BODIES CAMPAIGN, RIGHT?
THE WOMEN IN THE ADS WERE
LIKE -- WE'RE -- OUR BODY IS
NORMAL IN OUR UNDERWEAR.
BUY OUR SOAP.
RIGHT?
OKAY, OKAY, COOL, COOL.
HOW IS THAT SUPPOSED TO MAKE
ANYONE FEEL ANY BETTER?
SAYING YOUR BODY IS NORMAL IS
NOT A COMPLIMENT.
THE JOHN MAYER SONG WAS LIKE,
♪ YOUR BODY IS NORMAL
NORMAL BODY
♪♪ DON'T THINK IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN AS BIG OF A HIT, RIGHT?
MY HUSBAND TOLD ME I LOOKED
NORMAL ONCE.
I CRIED SO HARD MY FAKE
EYELASHES FELL OFF. YOU MIGHT
HAVE HEARD ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I
DID POST-IT ON FACEBOOK.
NOBODY INVITED ME TO THEIR
PARTIES THAT WEEK.